der ersten begegnung mit dem meer bis
bald
stellen sie sich vor sie hätten noch nie
das meer gesehen
den wind
die wellen dass wir auch schon noch nie
gehört
kein schiff das weit draußen
verschwindet keine sonne die leuchtend
rot untergeht
all das nie erfahren doch dann die
konzeptkünstlerin sowie carl sucht in
ihrer kunst immer noch intimen
persönlichen momenten nach augenblicken
die verwundern die berühren die man so
noch nie gesehen hat eines tages wollte
sie vom zauber des meeres erzählen
ich fuhr nach istanbul eine stadt die
von wasser umgeben ist
hier treffe ich menschen die noch nie
das meer gesehen haben
ich habe sie gefilmt ausgerechnet in
istanbul der stadt am bosporus
aus den bildern und videos wurde eine
ausstellung war lange das meer sehen zum
ersten mal